[Music]
welcome back to the show thank you for
joining us at the tony michaels podcast
we have a fantastic guest for you today
i'm gonna i'm gonna let her tell you all
about her resume because she's got a
hell of a story here uh rachel bit
by
how do you say it rachel how do you say
it so much better about my own shitty
hosting over the uh last couple of years
um now that you can't say my name
what is what is what is how do you say
the last name it's been a copper and
metal
so don't feel bad at all about it and
don't get square if you bastardize the
hell out of it because i'm not that's
not my name really technically i married
it well now i'll i'll say that i've i've
seen a couple different names that
you've been called because of your last
name doc is one of them right
doc b is one of them and i think there's
there's an election whisperer too
somewhere in there
so tell us about that tell us about that
yeah yeah i mean you know
it's funny because it kind of like
charts the odyssey right so i i um
when i first started talking about
seeing a um a rectangle where everybody
else saw a square or a triangle i guess
i would say where everybody else saw a
square in terms of
modern
uh voter behavior electoral strategy how
the two parties campaigned and
politicked
for control of government state and
federal level
like that stuff tied into my political
science background so i have a phd in
poli sci a specialty in american
politics and dissertation on
presidential nominations and on um
polarization and those things involve
the systemic scientific examination
database quantitative understanding of
of political phenomena which is a very
different way of understanding politics
than you would come at it from an
ideological perspective or an interest
perspective
or you know family like
engagement uh socialization into you
know political activity
um scientifically it's a system right
and you're understanding like how that
system works together the um you know
various components of american politics
the institutions that make up the system
the laws and then of course the people
and my area of specialty is really
understanding those the people
as they operate under the current
institutional cons you know construct of
our system
and um really in particular beginning to
recognize how polarization and hyper
partisanship had changed uh political
behavior and and applying that too to a
first election forecasting
i think more for fun but also like hey
guys like this is how stuff works and
when you understand this you can
anticipate and build a system around it
but you know as 2018 turned into 2020
and and uh
you know the stakes are really about
democratic stability right well and
democracy in general i mean right
democracy and this was i mean you know
the media is just so it's just so bad at
the narrative of the of the story of
what's happening right it's good all
these micro narratives but not the good
like collective story so like the
undermining of the election started
months before that with activity from
the rnc chair ronald mcdaniel
barr trump and many many other state
players
so it was quite obvious that they were
not going to accept the results of a
lost election well before the big lie
oh right well i mean the president
the president inside the press room was
asked that question at the time
president trump said we'll have to see
if we might not have a transfer of power
i mean he was he was not only projecting
it he was [ __ ] saying it out loud
yeah no no they weren't like that's i
think probably you know not to get off a
tangent but that's probably the most
frustrating part right it's like this is
all in plain sight so when i went on to
morning joe
what was it i think it was the georgia
survey right i ran i crowdsourced
because this is like the beginning of
moving from like an academic research
job to strike pac and i've always been
operating on limited resource so i
crowdsourced a survey
spent every dime of the of it i didn't
pay myself to do the survey and i
did the survey to show look
republicans in data are saying we have a
democratic crisis and that's because the
republican party has run this psych ops
on their base to tell them democrats
have stolen the election
and cheated and that's why they're
destroying the system like they think
they're protecting a system from us
and now luckily like other people are
surveying that and that's a narrative
that continues in polling data but like
i went on morning and i'm like hey you
know ronnie mcdaniel is traveling around
the whole she's gone to pennsylvania
michigan uh wisconsin all these swing
states and what they're doing is like
they did the reason that the um
you know the democratic governors like
evers and in pennsylvania had
so much trouble running the election and
all these lawsuits that mark elias had
to fight all of that should happen
because
when the pandemic hit people were like
okay it's dangerous to vote in person
especially for old people let's find a
way for people to vote remotely and the
gop is like oh [ __ ] no you're not doing
that right
well because they've seen that coming
and you know you know i um i i was
talking in uh twitter spaces today i
don't know if you've seen this or not
this twitter spaces but a lot of people
are organizing there and someone was
mentioning this and they were someone
said you know it used to be the
republicans that were all in for mail
ballots right like they pushed mail-in
ballots it was a republican thing that
was their push um because
to be honest
a big portion of the population over 65
generally voted republican and so that's
why they wanted a lot of those mail-in
ballots but their messaging has changed
because of the psyop that you're saying
is to convince them that democracy is
under attack by us so to defend the
constitution they have to tear it into
pieces or something and to be clear
about that guys the republicans invented
the vote by mail system change state
laws to create the system right violated
the [ __ ] down in florida which is like
when i did my first podcast with rick
wilson this is the thing i wanted him to
talk about they invented that [ __ ]
deployed it it's only when stacey abrams
adapted it for georgia in 2018
right and if beto had done the same
thing in texas like exactly do you think
he could have won probably yeah oh yeah
do you think stacy actually won in
georgia or do you think you know there
was no various there's no fraud in the
georgia election after the vote count
right when you are calling the voter
file to produce an outcome
right so what you're saying is what
you're saying is is georgia because i've
been saying this a lot on my show that
georgia and texas have been blue for a
long time it's this psyop that you're
talking about that not only um for years
and decades has encouraged white
republican people to turn out in droves
but to make non-white republican voters
go well we're losing we're going to lose
anyways and they've kind of flipped the
script isn't it isn't that why those
those that senate runoff in georgia
happened when trump went down there and
said oh they're gonna cheat anyways
they're gonna they're gonna [ __ ] rig
up the machines you know and and
basically
not only did he um engage
all those voters that went and voted for
ossoff and warnock but they but he also
suppressed his own vote by having that
message kind of
weirdly
in the opposite direction of what
they've always had yeah we really can't
know right we can't know that we know
what we can know from the data is this
that it's a it's a confluence of two
things the abrams operation
being perfected three-time deployment
right the governor's racing 18 the
initial run in 2020 which was successful
providing and almost um so close right
uh oh my god well yeah well i mean
without that race and and then that that
runoff because we were going to lose
that runoff right yeah we're supposed to
yeah yep so no doubt so without the law
you would lose right and then um and
then in addition to that right so you
have three iterations of this
like hyper intensive geo tv
coalitional turnout strategy that's the
gop's model right so like vote by nail
she took two things she took this this
absentee ballot like remote voting model
and then she took coalitional targeting
like i don't know how she thinks of this
because unfortunately i've never had an
opportunity to sit down with the same
rooms and discuss this i you know so
it's just well if i get her on my show
i'll bring you in and you i would really
love that
because i you know i know that we'd have
a fascinating conversation but i do know
that like incidentally or not that's
what they were focused on is like okay
let's make sure we hit our numbers in
our most
like compatible precincts and if we had
run that strategy in virginia which is
what i was arguing you know hey virginia
gop or
virginia dams
call me please somebody [ __ ] call me
like we need to run a certain strategy
i mean you're kind of in that position
right now right with these midterms is
you have a strategy but but i mean it it
it it seems like dims are waiting for
the right message to appear here and
it's like it's right in front of your
face um you know i've been saying it for
a long time that that politics and
government are two separate things like
government is the institution of
legislation and and policy and
ministering the government politics is
noise all of it all of its noise whether
it's from the right or the left and we
have to out-noise them they've always
been able to out-noise us and the reason
why is because they say [ __ ] in one loud
single voice the same thing over and
over they pound the hell of it whether
it makes sense or it's lies or it's not
they message because they do it all the
time and they don't stop and they pound
the drum and they're relentless well i
think
oh sorry
the other the other thing that you
remind me about how trump going down to
georgia and basically it's like they
and trump especially but the republican
party really has this ability to uh
create a faux affirmation
and that meaning like
it's not that it actually is gonna it
not that that it actually did happen
right and that they're saying that there
is voter fraud because there wasn't but
it's them putting it out there and
saying like
i'm now going to implant this seat in
everyone's brain as the possibility this
will happen
so when it doesn't have the outcome that
we want we can then scapegoat and say
this is what happens and it's like i
told you i put it out there i had
affirmation it was going to happen
and it did but no one there didn't larry
i mean we seen this in california the
recall and larry elder tried that and it
wasn't successful right right well
that's because he was i mean he was
blind
much worse than this like
so tell us tell us what we're missing on
that side
okay like it's more strategic than that
like okay and that if we could reach
that level of planning we would be like
in really good shape well let's let's
develop some strategy we're here let's
do it let's let's mix the pot yeah i
mean like they they started planning
like how
to win 22 or 2020
even if they lost 2020 a year out
right and started to lay
like the groundwork of that messaging
through their ecosystem which by the way
i mean so you're you know what gabe i
almost cut you off again and the reason
why was because i i wanted to make sure
everyone hearing my voice understands
that system is part of a strategy that
was a strategic plan that they came up
with in their little brain trust 15 20
years ago based on the [ __ ] global
diaries no doubt
right and they're like hey you know we
can control information we can you know
they have a system that they
strategically designed and deployed that
is what i am arguing we have to do it's
not
so yeah it's messaging but that's just a
component part our problem is not
messaging it's a what is this problem
our entire system
is a decentralized laxadazzical tactical
heavy mess right i mean i can't even i
can even tell you from my personal
experience when i worked i was in
milwaukee for college and i worked on
the obama campaign
and i went out to go
uh make sure that voters knew where to
go for election day and another reason
why you know republicans are so against
mail-in voting or or what have you is
because just the availability of
uh during covid right you're at home you
have more free time you can actually
show up or mail the ballot but in
milwaukee one thing i actually witnessed
firsthand was
uh i would go and verify that the people
knew where they actually had to vote and
what i found out was that they were you
know malicious of course
fake
uh info like flyers that told them to go
to a specific location which wasn't in
fact actually a polling place and then
what happens is those people because of
course like you're like well it's
election day it's not a holiday so i
have to work so then they say all right
i'm gonna go to the polling place they
show up it's not they're like well [ __ ]
i gotta go to work and then by the end
of the day they're super tired and the
polling place is either a commute away
or it's they're tired or what have you
and by then they're like boom that's
someone who would have voted against us
that's off the list
and that and so i had to go around
this [ __ ] for 2020 it was okay guys like
so like i said they said ronna and barr
was involved in this too so like don't
let him pretend like at the end he got a
bad thing
but he got a bad day was jail okay
that's just a fascist will fascist until
he's threatened with handcuffs yeah he
was fine with like invisible coup like
right exactly yeah so like they go to
pennsylvania and they meet with the
state legislature there and they're like
don't give the governor the ability like
go after hard the ability to vote by man
right because like you're going to lose
that and unlike like on the left so it's
like it's what drives me nuts
yesterday somebody randomly emailed me i
had my professor
he [ __ ] talked about you in class
history he loves you
he thinks you're like brilliant not
enough he says your strategy is right on
and i'm like oh my god who is it i think
it's a colleague right like an
ex-colleague i'm like oh
who actually likes my [ __ ] you know
and no it's the next romney campaign
strategist right and of course right
always the republicans recognize because
it comes from them right like so they go
to pennsylvania and they get all the
state legislatures to fight these voting
reforms so that they can then say
like so like within the smart circles of
the fraud of the big lie
it's not the like that it's not the
voting machine [ __ ] right
in their in in their rationale the way
that these people are sleeping at night
to throw
overthrow the government
is they have rationalized
that the governors in these states
overrode the will of the legislatures
and changed unilaterally election law
right that's what their moral
justification is they leave out the
context the context is
that in the heart of a pandemic that was
there was no vaccine for
the gop's official position at the state
level was [ __ ] you go vote and die if
you want to vote right they wanted to
win
so like the reason the governors had to
act unilaterally was if they didn't
their residents either would have to
vote or die right
so
like then so then they they also go in
once they lose those legal fights and
mark elias if you brought him on the
show he'd be able to tell you this [ __ ]
like well dm mark and tell him to come
on my show i'll bring him through the
legal story right because the legal
story is they try to sue
right to get these law in the governor's
autonomy and when they lose that fight
then they turn to something else and
that's to counting the ballots so in
michigan and pennsylvania in wisconsin
like on election night at so i don't
know 8 39 when the world was still up in
arms like i knew that biden had won i
also knew that the democrats had [ __ ]
up the down ballot so what what gave it
away for you then we'll talk about so
like the reason
the reason i knew biden had won is i
knew he had won the three midwestern
states as the forecast had anticipated
and the reason i do that is that the
in-person daily vote totals and the
margins that trump had were going to be
insufficient
once the uh absentee ballots were
counted now none of the absentee ballots
had been counted in those states and the
reason why was part of the republican
party's pr
because they wanted to use that as part
of the big lie right exactly so like the
plan was to keep the margins so tight
on election night in pa
in michigan whatever that voters would
go to bed and then they could litigate
the margins right and start to exclude
ballots or whatever and then even if
they lost that then they could at least
make a compelling case about it being
stolen so like what they've ended up
doing is selling the same line but
they've been selling it with no evidence
well and that's the worst evidence like
these days you don't have to well at
least trump and his party is i don't
have to show evidence i just have to
make the claim and if i say it loud
enough then it's true but it's but but
isn't it true that they really they at
the end of the day they didn't i mean
trump maybe himself but the republican
party didn't give a [ __ ] if the uh the
election got overturned it was about the
noise and what i mean by that is that
they they knew going to federal court i
mean even rudy giuliani had to sit in
front of federal judges and say no we're
not talking about fraud right
and but they didn't [ __ ] play that
they didn't play that on fox news they
weren't pumping that inch out into their
ethos and the reason why is because
their message was simple get the sheep
to believe that it was stolen right i
mean that's the whole point is they
don't need to know the truth we want
them to have the truth that we want them
to have and they'll act on the truth
that
i mean i've had that conversation with
tons of people you know through all the
various videos i've done uh satirical
about the election which is somebody
saying
there was voter fraud in these states
and then it's like okay well you know
how about you
present some evidence of this and
they're like well and they come up with
some bs reason because they don't have
any reason because fox news and other
places are just blasting this noise
right and the real signal throughout all
the noises
there was no fraud but to them they hear
oh as fraud and on you know then the
suitcases and the late night drop-offs
oh and [ __ ] the jumps and the errors
and the [ __ ] bamboo balances
just crazy as [ __ ] so like the the long
like the point of all of that is like
you're against an opposition that is
strategically planning against you and
also willing to do and say anything to
beat you right right
right right
well take the constitution and wipe
their ass with it i mean almost
literally they were smearing [ __ ] on the
walls in the capitol i mean this is this
is absolutely crazy to me that knowing
what well
i say us because i've studied the second
world war right you think americans
would know this by now that
that
when trump did what he wanted to
accomplish which was tear down the
constitution like what did you think he
was going to do did you think he was
just going to be like oh that
constitution it's a swell thing or
was he or did you think he was going to
be like oh well [ __ ] the constitution it
doesn't mean anything i i destroyed it
and it's like you
what did you expect
that was going to be the result of him
absolutely undoing the actual norm of
democracy now i believe that their plan
was delusional um i'm actually an
optimist i don't believe that they got
as close as people say i mean i i
understand the fear of it and that we
want to protect our democracy but i
really don't think the is the eastman
memo the plan for the cheeto dust
kangaroo was in any kind of coupled way
into reality uh mike pence even if he
would have tried to do what they wanted
to do i actually don't think it would
have accomplished what they wanted to
accomplish other than to delay and
perpetuate the big lie until january
20th because they knew biden was going
to be sworn in on the 20th regardless
the states had already certified so it
was all just what you're saying it was
this perpetuation of getting people to
believe not as necessarily in reality
but get people to believe that this [ __ ]
is true right i'm gonna push back hard
on that go ahead go ahead go ahead
if you disagree with me
yeah there's it's absolutely true
there's a major ops like a psych ops
right a propaganda effort a global style
serious
massive money massive organizational
effort
into the part that you're describing and
that is an important component but let
me tell you that is the backup plan like
that right so like the eastman approach
of having pence refused us to show up
and do this right you're right i mean
that means that maybe that goes
somewhere at the end of the day if you
don't control the military
right you don't right
right right which is why now like
they're they're investing all this money
and psych ops on bannon's operation to
divide the military right so you know i
mean because well yeah they're all in
with bannon because he's the key to the
next coup right don't you think oh yes
no and so like so but when when when you
say that it was all about the gaslight
no no absolutely not i mean let me make
this really [ __ ] clear go ahead
we are only sitting in a democracy right
now because at the end of the day
a handful maybe 10 people
at the end of the day wouldn't play ball
okay and if they had they could have it
wouldn't necessarily have transferred to
trump keeping power but it could have
spun us off into total martial law well
yeah authoritarianism
right so like the coup pop like
powerpoint plan
makes it clear
we're gonna do this thing
and they
through the courts had already proven
the election was free fair and
completely fraud free right so like they
could not in their own powerpoint to try
to lure in other republicans use that
approach they're like okay we're going
to pretend there's foreign interference
and then we'll declare a national
security emergency
there's your martial law you're starting
to sound like mike flynn you're starting
to sound like michael
to bring people in when they saw floated
it through their most trusted network
right and so like then it was like okay
armed insurrection at the capitol right
martial law right so like that was the
the like the climax of the coup
plot and he punched i mean i i don't
ever want to compare myself to donald
trump ever i've never done this before
this is [ __ ] his this is history
you're making history oh well let's do
it let's let's do it everyone listen to
something that donald trump and i have
in [ __ ] common is desperation i'm
desperate to save democracy he's
desperate to destroy it and you know
with all the resources of the presidency
he had a shitty
mission right so like he hammered every
[ __ ] source he had in every like
state and every avenue to try to get
someone to help him do that to destroy
democracy and i'm doing the same thing
like i'm on your pod i'm on twitter i'm
telling everyone i know and like look i
got to get this plan in front of people
like they i can't put it on the internet
because then they have it right right
you got to get it you got to get it in
the right hand
so you know but like that persistence
like i want to be clear like we are
[ __ ] lucky to be living in our
democracy it is you know you know that's
a good point
that's a good point because back to the
whole eastman memo and mike pence isn't
it isn't it actually
beyond parody that dan quayle the guy
who couldn't
spell potato actually may have convinced
mike pence to save democracy it is
absolutely [ __ ] bonkers that that
that is that that is the actual [ __ ]
history that people are going to tell
like the guy who couldn't spell potatoes
saved us like what the [ __ ] i mean try
to imagine the political world if pence
had done that it's so like yeah the act
itself like the illegal right that's a
small thing but the the cataclysm that
could have come out of that especially
given like you know they had not done
enough they i know if bannon has one
[ __ ] regret guys i know what it is
what is that he did not they sent last
minute [ __ ] over to dod and that's how
you also know all this [ __ ] was in
motion well in advance because they
started making those appointments in
november in the dod right um
bannon's one regret is is that they
didn't [ __ ] infiltrate dod more
aggressively and early on right well and
they're still trying to do it like you
said by by actually actively recruiting
members of not just law enforcement but
the military into their little fascist
movement here oh they have a whole
operation right
right
nothing well
right right well so so so on a lighter
note we love to play trivia here on the
podcast and i'm so glad to have you
because um you're so blunt but but
because that's that's my style right i
don't give a [ __ ] not two [ __ ] i don't
think you give two [ __ ] you're ready to
fight but you're so educated and you
have such a enormous amount of knowledge
so i i but we like to play trivia so i
want to get to that knowledge because
i'm sure gabe's got some questions to
ask me and you there is no prize but
let's let's play trivia
[Music]
okay
all right guys i'm gonna ask you five
multiple choice questions each question
is worth one point the first one to ring
in on their buzzer will get a chance to
answer the question get it wrong and
your opponent will have a shot for the
point whoever has the most points after
five questions are you ready i'm ready
probably gonna lose this go ahead
question number one
what was the worst finish in history for
an incumbent president running for
reelection
millet fillmore in 1856
b herbert hoover in 1932
c william howard taft in 1912
or d uh
[Music]
uh
donald trump
i'm gonna go with something earlier
i i think i think hoover i think hoover
i'm gonna go with phil moore oh you're
both wrong the answer
was
c
howard william taft i knew it happened
because
well yeah because because teddy
roosevelt teddy roosevelt came in and
he's like no you're not going to rerun
and he started his own party and he
[ __ ] him up did you know you know that
that's a funny story a lot of people
don't know the story about teddy
roosevelt like everyone's like jimmy
carter is the baddest ass president
you know former president which he is
but people don't know that teddy
roosevelt is one of the baddest ass
former presidents he actually went after
he was president he went down to south
america and he
he [ __ ] went on a river there's a
book about it i can't remember the name
he went on the river he almost died his
son almost died there was like four
people that died i mean it was he when
he came back to the united states he was
like thin as a toothpick he was on
death's bed and he came back and he um i
think it was like three months later
after he came back he gave this big
speech
and i don't remember exactly where he's
at but it was like a thousand degrees
and teddy roosevelt is still on his
deathbed basically and he gives up and
gives like an hour speech he was such a
[ __ ] badass well there's even better
something even better more badassy about
teddy that i don't i don't think go
ahead
because i thought you were going to wrap
around to it but you know that
[ __ ] got shot once and gave it
yeah
yeah you did
i was just gonna
well i mean we could also you know that
it that does remind me of uh
that that does remind me was is it
andrew jackson that uh he had the duel
got shot and then still like
and then it's and then the bullet stayed
in him to the day that he died was that
what it was it's possible i i'm trying
to i remember because i think it was
talked about in the the book american
line which is the
hell yeah hell yeah get shot and then
predict the outcome of the election
[Laughter]
all right question number two
which of these candidates won the
presidency but lost the state they lived
in
oh wow okay hold on
a richard nixon
b james polk
c donald trump
d woodrow wilson e all of the above well
i guess all of them well trump did for
sure he didn't lose win new york but
what's your answer what's your answer
yeah all right well i didn't even listen
because i decided it was al gore and
then i stopped listening because i you
know
so like what huh um what was just get a
what was a all right so a richard nixon
b james polk c donald trump d woodrow
wilson e all the above yeah i just have
to eliminate one as winning nixon's from
cali
he probably won callie
yeah i'm gonna go with just trump
incorrect tony um all of the above
correct
nixon and trump both lost new york
wilson lost new jersey and polk lost
tennessee so nixon lost new york but but
but he was cali right see that's where i
was confused because i figured nixon
would be counting see he pulled a trick
one on us there rachel yeah and i helped
you i did the jeopardy assist i liked it
right right right that's that's how i
was i was nearing down i'm like ah
because what happens when there's no
incentive i mean i know
i mean whoever wins you know can hold it
over the other person's head on that my
intention is to use these questions that
i don't know the answers to to uh
filibuster and make sure i come off
sounding smart about
that's right that's right that's right
well we like to have fun here on the
podcast and trivia is always fun and the
audience the audience loves it what's
question number three all right so
question number three in terms of the
popular vote what was the closest
presidential election in history
a 1824 andrew jackson versus john quincy
adams b 1880 between james a garfield
versus winfield scott hancock c 1888
between benjamin harris and grover
cleveland or d
2000
george w bush versus al gore okay here's
what i know about this like i know that
there are a few electoral college
popular vote splits
in that list
i don't know what the margins were
specifically down to like the ballot
number in those others but i do not know
that 2000 was really close and it's 500
000.
so it's the only since it's you know
it's the only information i have i'll
have to go with that uh answer that is
incorrect
uh tony um
i'm gonna i'm just gonna throw a dart in
the dark here and go with b i don't know
that is correct
1880.
[Laughter]
honestly honestly the the um because
what year was that what year was that
1880 james garfield versus william scott
hancock or winfield scott hancock
is it is this the one and rachel maybe
you know um is this the one that really
came into play with because uh they
always harken back with this january 6
stuff to an election and they're like oh
well it happened in this year and it's
like yeah but their three states
couldn't certify their votes that's why
it happened that way
in this case
in 2020 all the states had certified
their votes so you're what you're saying
is true but it's not true like
and josh hawley did this thing right
oh now right now you sound like a
democrat right
despite despite capturing fewer than 2
000 more popular votes than hancock
garfield was easily elected easily
elected capturing 214 of the 369
electoral votes cast
okay so so we had a 2016 type back then
in 1880 i guess yeah the biggest turnout
you know
okay well it happens it happens yeah all
right question number four
what newspaper
famously went to press with the headline
dewey defeats truman in the 1948
presidential election i haven't seen
that newspaper headlines so many times
the albany new york times union
uh b the chicago daily news
see the chicago daily tribune or d the
new york post
and c is correct the chicago
trade
i i wasn't sure i wasn't sure which
chicago paper it was yeah if a former
student of mine was to ever listen to
this they would tell you right away i
never tested my students on like on
multiple choice like i use that like but
i'm not like this
because that's hard these are some of
these i don't even know myself so you
guys are doing better than i would
uh all right question
question number five i do have a bonus
question that you know obviously because
right now i believe the score is two to
one
uh with tony in the lead so question
five
which one of these presidents did not
win the nobel peace prize
a jimmy carter b franklin delano
roosevelt c barack obama
or d woodrow wilson woodrow wilson
incorrect
it's up to you now i couldn't i don't
know it's got to be a then huh no jimmy
carter did win a no-brainer wait no not
eight i'm sorry b
okay i forgot about carter
like everybody else in america
b is correct franklin delano roosevelt
he didn't win one he didn't win one i
would put my money on that if you know
who else didn't win one trump yeah yeah
[Laughter]
even though i've heard i've seen so many
people online go he was nominated and i
go yeah and the guy who nominates anyone
geeking out right anyone i got nominated
right well you know what you know what's
funny about that is he really is so
[ __ ] butt hurt about that like he is
that he doesn't win awards and [ __ ]
because you know he even like makes the
fake magazine covers and hangs him up
behind him and [ __ ] which time time
magazine came and was like can you take
that down from your wall such a [ __ ]
fraud he's such a [ __ ] broad but yeah
he's got he's got those photos of the
inauguration biggest turnout biggest
numbers ever well we remember the sean
spicer moment everyone remembers that
i'm not talking about the one where he
went on dances with stars i'm talking
about you're not talking about the one
where he used to be the easter bunny at
the white house no no no i'm talking
about it
we like the clown here no no i'm at the
the one where he you know he was talking
about dixon i mean crowd size you know
right got it okay right yeah
okay
the score now is two to two oh so we
have a tie breaker here okay all right
question
question six
who was the youngest man to be
inaugurated president a bill clinton b
john f kennedy c theodore roosevelt or d
abraham lincoln i'm going kennedy myself
so i don't know what you want to go with
you want to go with that together
go ahead go ahead go ahead you you go no
i think we should go in together
okay so so which one are you going with
well i feel like isn't kennedy like the
most famous like barack obama was talked
about i remember as the youngest after
kennedy right well
yeah i'll go with i'll go with clinton
how does you think clinton was younger
well no but i mean i'll go with clinton
you took mine
so i'll go clinton
because i'm jumpy and i never give
anybody oh it was your answer
who is it gabe who is it all right so
let me the uh the answers that you guys
are giving are bill clinton and what was
the other one and kennedy yeah yeah no
kennedy and clinton it's got to be one
of the two of them right i think no
incorrect
the answer is see theodore roosevelt he
was the [ __ ] we were just talking about
teddy how did we not know this rachel he
was uh uh the youngest person at the age
of 42. he is more of a badass he is more
of a badass and we gave him credit no
wonder he could start keep giving us
what's he got
well the other thing no wonder no wonder
he went down to
south america and discovered a river
everyone's gotta go read that book it's
basically like the tom brady of
presidents you know he is yeah he's the
ghost you know what i [ __ ] love you
know what that's because that back in
those days
progressivism was a it was a was you
know liberalism progressivism was a also
a republican thing right
yeah yeah yeah you had him on both sides
right yes yes i mean so like when you
know that's why we really [ __ ] need
people who understand political
development and political behavior and
all you know under you know
have taken some time to read some [ __ ]
dude because like the the parties are
different the people in the parties are
different the idea there used to be
mixed ideologies in the parties so you
had liberal republicans and conservative
democrats of course compromise and [ __ ]
was like mansion he lives in this world
and
you might want to tell the people that
believe the republicans
when they bring up the argument like
well republicans saved the day and did
this and i'm like okay that is the same
republican party democrats are started
the kkk right yeah but you know what
it's the same the people right white and
southern conservatives right right those
people are the same they're still in the
south
they're just right they're just
coalesced around the republican party as
opposed to divide it up
and the ideology is the same right
they're conservatives and they used to
be in the democratic party because that
was a big coalition party that was from
the new deal on controlled american
politics at least in congress right
because of that unholy alliance between
liberal
democrats and and conservative democrats
in the south that [ __ ] got washed out
with the civil rights and voting rights
act in the 60s that's when that
realignment happened down there now that
realignment's happening nationally
everywhere and if you don't understand
that how the [ __ ] are you gonna win
elections
god damn she's spot on all right i'm
gonna end the game in the game stay
right here
[Music]
so to your point at the end of the game
there rachel because i remember a moment
then i've watched the tape several times
when harry s truman um stood on at the d
and the democrat national convention and
he basically said
to all the southern democrats um the the
quote-unquote racist he basically said
not so many words because i'm not near
as articulate as harry astrum was but he
said you can be racist you just can't be
racist here anymore and that really
started this
this um transition to maybe where we're
at today like what the parties look like
now it took decades and decades and and
you know we had we had the christian
movement that took over the
conservatives and they you know because
christians in america really weren't
engaged in politics but they found a way
to really you know enrage them and make
them fearful and uh use abortion is
basically you know to get them engaged
in other politics but you know that's
where it started was all the way back
then um and into the civil rights
movement and beyond and to where we are
today where you know there is no
liberal um con
republican no conservative democrat
which there are there are
but it just we can't get past
these labels of of what we have
well i mean it's kind of more complex
than that i mean certainly
the in terms of ideological homogeneity
right and you can see this quite clearly
even though it's a noisy indicator
self-identified ideology
if you look at that bi-party in any
public opinion data um which i've
provided before in national data you'll
see okay you ask democrats like are you
liberal very liberal liberal moderate
conservative and you ask republicans
that and then you look at those
distributions and in the republican
group the modal the most common response
by far is conservative and then moderate
in the democratic group it's moderate
okay
then liberal so like that's a big
difference right when like you're when
you're when your core partisans not like
the base as you would think about like a
fox breathing phone breathing
for 30 of america republican party
versus the democrats
um is it's modal ideology is not
moderation it's it's the ideology it's
organized as an ideological movement
where the democrats clearly
are group interest oriented right so
like there's so many
like behavioral underpinning
psychological underpinnings to how
you've ended up with the system you have
and the parties you have and people you
have in them
um but the but the fact is you know
these 30 40 years out of this 50 years
of the civil rights legislation in the
60s
and this nationalization of the southern
realignment which has gone through the
midwest and the west and and now we have
we have um you know loss of white
working class or non-college educated
whites really non-college educated
minority voters who are now being
targeted at the same messaging
techniques that were targeted initially
with those fight voters um
you know and people are i think kind of
aware of that but what people what gets
lost in that is the other half of the
realignment the alignment story which is
college educated whites who are moving
at college educated voters not not just
whites but all college educated voters
who are moving very heavily to the
democratic party as the republican party
began to position itself in ways that
made it more attractive to these
non-college educated voters it isolated
college-educated voters right right so
like we
we have inefficiencies because there's
this there are it's true that there are
more non-college educated people than
there are college educated people and in
their presidential election that's a
particularly important fact but in
midterms and other cycles
college education is going to be a major
predictor of participation when you see
drop off you're going to see it
predominantly come out of that
non-educated pool and number two
like we are not doing any strategic
outreach any messaging any brand
reinforcement loyalty [ __ ] so this is
all the work that i you know have under
strike pack
in like in enhancing our own realignment
we spend so much time
fruitlessly trying to hold on or or
prevent i mean we should do that work
and we do it wrong right now we need to
do it we need to do it right um but we
have to be leaning into our own
realignments and enhancing that brand
breakage um that we could be milking in
places like orange county and others
right where there's a lot of people who
are voting now for republicans off of
previous brand identification you know
low taxes good for the economy that's
that's all they know they don't follow
the news they follow the headlines no
idea
the gop is ready to install an autocracy
what that would mean for them right it's
a bread and butter issue for every
family in america because when autocracy
hits a country it is at your kitchen
table it listens to every conversation
you have it infects it infects your own
relatives turns them into little
mini breakfast narcs right so like
everybody there economically will be
affected they'll be affected in their
private
choices um you know the idea of limited
government does not mix with autocracy
at all gun ownership right there's so
many ways in which you know for every
single person autocracy is directly
personal right and we are not
communicating that at all well i i i
think you're absolutely correct i i hate
when they say big government you know
you have ron desantis talking about big
government more local government and
then here they are smashing up local
governments decisions and power
using the big state government to to
really you know uh put a wet wet cloth
over what local governments want to do
in school boards and city councils it's
it's all [ __ ] but i want to go back
to two words that you said you said
strategic outrage i i actually say this
a lot i say stay pissed and go [ __ ]
vote like i think that's one thing that
the democrats and people are frustrated
with the democrats and and i don't mean
like us democrat voters i mean democrats
on the hill some of the consultants on
the hill possibly if you want to lump
them in but they they
they have they're all over the map with
messaging and you know um they want to
say all these things and that's what
gets democrats fighting with each other
when like let's just get one one little
thing that we all are for which is
democracy i believe this big tent party
let's do that and message that and the
and the strategic outrage because i
think that's one thing that like you
were saying republicans understand that
democrats do not and and my democrats i
do mean the voters moderates and people
who vote liberal and and that sort of
thing is they don't understand that
that that staying pissed about your
democracy and being outraged and your
your weapon to to do or to use on that
is your vote and that ballot um so i
like that phrase strategic outrage but
tell us why the dems
you know is there a reason why they suck
at messaging is the reason why
republicans are better at these you know
like build a wall and lock her up and
you know they have these let's go
brandon yeah there's no system there's
no so like when you when you're when
you're looking at like why
does it seem like there's no strategy
there is no strategy and the reason
there is no strategy is that currently
the way our system is designed not
theirs ours is there's no brain trust we
have institutions and organizations that
are tasked with specific components
um and they don't really talk to each
other and even if they did
like you know they're concerned with
like one aspect and they're designing
micro like if if you could call it
strategy micro strategy and then
deploying tactics to achieve those goals
what what they do over there is a
holistic party-wide strategy like the
yunkan campaign was not cooked up and
run in virginia by the consultants that
he hired right right and they had a
digital strategy
and that coordinated campaign that means
field or whatever the hell right like
they had a strategy right cooked in a
lab
that was optimized based off of modern
voter behavior which is conditioned off
of partisanship first before you get
down to demographics right
of a sophisticated database that they've
created that's centralized and everybody
uses and they used it to hit
presidential [ __ ] turnout in their
best precincts in a mid uh you know
basically a midterm cycle so you know
all i am saying is let's do what they're
doing all right let's build a strategic
you know um brain
machine and you know we've got all this
tactical arsenal
that's sitting around some of it needs
some optimization but generally the r d
money and infrastructure has been built
is just
it's just sitting there being used
inefficiently
and wrong in many cases just
wrong so it's inefficient and wrong and
like if we were to get together like if
you were to put me in a room with five
people with a lot of authority and money
we could quickly
organize this into a strategic framework
for 22 that will give us absolutely the
only chance we have of holding off a
midterm effect i don't know if jamie
harrison is listening but if he's
listening um
maybe
maybe maybe get dropping the dm with
rachel and uh we can get you guys in a
room i you know everyone wants to
because i don't want people to think
that uh demonizing the dnc or
quote-unquote democratic party is the
right
right
it's just it's just that they're not
doing it correctly is is the criticism
right it's not that it's not that they
can't or they won't or they don't know
how right no like it's not it's not it's
like these people are not bad people
jamie harrison tom perez it doesn't
matter who you throw in the dnc if the
system isn't it's not the person it's
the system okay
how they work though like with with you
know like what you're saying they have
this machine and it doesn't really
matter who operates as long as you
operate it right well also there's no
machine like jamie is operating the
democratic national committee it is
basically an institution
okay
and it does specific things and he runs
a business basically right so that's
what he's doing people the thing what i
am saying is
we need to create the job that people
think jamie has
and is never the [ __ ] maniac and
trumpian as it sounds right with the i
alone can fix it [ __ ]
i have spent months working on on like a
military science based like strategic
plan
and it goes down like you know it goes
it's very detailed and it and it's and
it's not going to get the consultants
will still make money and people will
still be in charge of the ship they want
to be in charge of and it just organizes
things into a strategic framework
that is it's based on strategic consent
intent and objectives
that are achieved they're all achievable
too because you know we're really
talking about a very tight timeline
we're talking about very high stakes
right so this is a very doable
executable plan
but it
it absolutely requires a centralization
that's going to sit above
these
massive infrastructure universe
and you know deploy this plan
you know i think
i think
when you say it like that like the dnc
is an institution and what they really
need is a plan so everyone can
coordinate together
because
i i think people get confused when
people say we need to do what the
republicans do like like oh well you
want to lie cheat and steal not like no
no no no that's not what i'm talking
about yeah i'm just talking about
strategically organized to win like our
goal should be to win because i hear
this so many times like well how are we
going to do this thing and how are we
going to get this legislation and what
if this is in this bill and what if this
ain't like how the [ __ ] do you think any
of that shit's going to get in a bill if
the republicans have control like none
of that [ __ ] that you want or want to do
is not going to get in any [ __ ] bill
anywhere you think mitch mcconnell is
going to bring is going to bring decent
[ __ ] health care to the floor of the
senate [ __ ] no no
no he's not yeah no [ __ ] and people want
to focus on mansion well why is mansion
no mansions no because he faces a
[ __ ] electorate this 80 percent
republican okay so right now is still
coming from that problem guys
you know that's the problem we need to
focus on and and so yes like that's i'm
really glad that we ended up on this
tangent and that's why it's great to do
organic shows like this because at the
end of the day
everyone wants as passionate and they
are passionate about their personal
you know contributions and they're all
valuable like i said like and that's
contribution is valuable it's all it's
all important and we can use it all but
we have to use it
in a specific way and we don't
have time to [ __ ] around right right we
need to do it now and i failed to get
that across
in 2021
because you know i'm
i'm not perfect either you know and i
and i i wanted to explain like we're not
doing messaging well we're not doing
branding or doing branding and and like
we did that part well and i'm proud of
what we've achieved with strike pack but
at the end of the [ __ ] day we have to
compete in like 30 arenas and the model
that i've designed for the d-trip and
the dscc to do that in
like it involves um
a comprehensive cohesive
competition model
that you know it doesn't take a little
it it it doesn't take any more money
than they're gonna spend but it spends
it differently and it spends it more
efficiently
but it's but the point is you can't do
what i want to do without a lot of money
and no one's going to give it to me
that's just fine i understand that so
like we will get this plan to people
however we can get it to we're not
proprietary
about strike pack we're not prepared to
worry about me like i don't know you
want to win democracy
like whatever the [ __ ] point is like
i don't even care if honestly i don't
even care if they want to take my plan
and kick me the [ __ ] out of the room
just take the plan
at least listen to this plan so everyone
i guarantee you nobody has ever laid
[ __ ] out like this for you if your name
is barack obama or hillary clinton or
whatever right a person that could make
this happen so so everyone listening out
there to the interview we'll cut this
little clip out and you can just pound
the dnc and the d triple c tag them uh
dm them um get rachel in front of
someone over there let's get rachel and
jamie harrison in the same same room for
at least i don't know 30 minutes before
he kicks her out and steals her plan and
we and she saves democracy once and for
all rachel it really is a super pleasure
to have you on and come back anytime um
we've been doing these little pop-ins on
the show where we take a small topic and
have someone pop in and give us uh
commentary you are welcome anytime to
come on the show if you have something
that you want to talk about i i believe
that you're in it for the good fight
i think i think more than anything
um your message of messaging the
pro-democracy but more than that to
actually get a
a cohesive
a coordinated strategic outrage right
maybe that's maybe that's the three word
it's kind of long words like it's
strategic outrage you know that's right
democrats love three things
i always i always just
deliver right i mean that's it the gift
i ever gave so so before we go
just tell people democrats delivered so
before we go because i want you to do a
shameless plug so tell us about where we
find you where where people can retweet
you and and and share your message but
tell us about the hashtag democrats
deliver as well
well that yeah that's just out there i
mean that's something that we put out um
you know
and said hey everyone like this is
something that came out of my brain just
one day as a brain fart basically and
that's how that stuff goes and and it's
a campaign i think the party was more
able or receptive to embrace because it
is positive right right um but it is
negative too guys i tricked like tricked
the democratic party into picking up one
of my double entendre branding uh
phrases because it implies democrats
deliver implies that republicans don't
right
right
which is true which is all true
it's funny because it's true
yeah so i'm talking about efficiencies
on top of efficiencies measures counter
measures counter measures on top of
counter measures man we could [ __ ] these
people up but we got to get in the arena
first god damn i love that i love that
language so where do we find you where
do we where where do people retweet you
where where do people share your message
yeah so strike pac has a launch
basically we just spent a startup year
um you know launching with grassroots
support and you know we love our
grassroots donors and we um have a
launch package i think it consists of
like nine ads that kind of show out do
branding messaging
how to do a motive stakes framing stuff
how nationalization's supposed to work
not not the stuff that the mcauliffe
team put out in virginia um you know
it's a small
small sample of of what it should look
like and um limited by our operation
budget but it is a great
taste of what we could be doing
if we can get more people read into this
model we can get some more money raised
if you want to contribute that's great
uh and that's at strikepack.com follow
me on twitter at rachelbinikoffer follow
the strike pack account too though or
you don't don't follow me there you go
so spell bit spell bit of coffer because
i butchered it in the beginning tell us
how to spell it yeah i'm luckily like
the only one right because who the hell
and i'll put it i'll put it on the
screen for everyone so they clear oh
okay good yeah that's great no spelling
for us for the people it's r-a-c-h-e-l
b-i-t-e like the word bite c-o-f as in
frank er go to bite coffer
even though you know that's that's great
thank you for joining us and again i i'm
serious when i say you're welcome back
any time just you know send a message if
there's something that you'd like to
talk about and come on the show you know
you know we're gonna be switching to a
daily format two hours a day so i'm
gonna have plenty of time for people to
talk i want to spread the message in
2022 as far and wide as we [ __ ] can
so stay pissed go [ __ ] vote because
democrats deliver
and that's the message
rachel thank you for joining us i really
appreciate it everyone stay stay with us
we'll be right back right after this
break